kaldı iz kaldı Menzil kaldı uzakta
emmesi
çıksa Boran köşse kumlar hem gömülmez
izimiz Tok temas Kervan yoliddin Gerçi
atlar bekoruk tapusu bu izni bir gün
nevrimiz ya evremiz
Doğu türkistan'ın Vatan ve İstiklal
şairi
Abdurrahim ökkör'ün iş şiiriyle
selamlamak istedim sizlere hoş geldiniz
Bizler kaldı çok uzaklarda
Fırtınalar kopsa da kumlar savrulsa da
bu iz gömülmez
Kervan yoluna devam edecek Gerçi
atlarımız zayıf ama bu izi bir gün
torunlarımız ya da onların çocukları
bulacak
Doğu türkistan'ın eski adıyla şarki
Türkistan bugünkü adıyla
Çin canlı Uygur Özerk bölgesinden
kaşgardan sesleniyor Şair bize kaşgar
islamiyetle buluştuğumuz bir nokta
budizmle İslamiyetin buluştuğu yer Yusuf
Has Hacip balasagunluyuz kaşgarda
yazıyor eserini ilk İslami Eser
kutadguiliği
Siyasetname ve ideal insanı arayan Eser
Kaşgarlı Mahmut Türkçenin bilinen ilk
sözlüğünü kaşgarda yazmaya başlıyor
Bağdat'ta tamamlıyor bütün Türk
dillerini derliyor
gece gündüz uyumadan Türk dünyası çok
geniş bir coğrafya Kuzey buz denizinden
güneyde tibet'e şimdi denizinden
adriyatik denizine kadar bu geniş alanda
Türkler farklı dinlerle buluşmuşlar
farklı alfabeler kullanmışlar o kadar ki
Türkler kadar çeşitli alfabe kullanan
bir millet daha yok
Budist Türkler
lamayıst Türkler şaman Türkler hala
Ortodoks Türkler
Gregoryan kıpçaklar Müslüman Türkler
alfabelerimiz runik alfabe ötüken'den
sonra
soğut alfabesi budizmle arkasından
islamiyetle Arap alfabesi ve Anadolu'nun
ortasında bizim Ortodoks
karamanlılarımız Grek harflerini
kullandılar Batu
Ukrayna'da kıpçaklar Ermeni harflerini
kullandılar bir avuç Karay Polonya ve
litvanya'da ibrani harfleriyle yazıyor
Musevi kararlar
Latin alfabesi ve Sovyet hakimiyetindeki
bütün Rusya Türklüğü pirel alfabesi
hangi dine inanırsa inansın hangi
coğrafyada hangi din olursa hangi Alfa
ve olursa olsun ortak olan bir şey vardı
millet adı ve dil adı
Orhan anıtlarını hatırlayınız
sizlere sorarsam ilk edebi dilimiz hangi
eserlerdir orhun'u anıtları Bilge Kağan
orada ebedi devlet ebedi millet
anlayışından bahsediyor
önüne koyduğu ilk Hedef Bu ne diyor
bağımsız ve refah içinde yaşayacak Türk
milleti Evet sabımın tükettiği eşittir
sözlerimi iyi dinleyin Ötüken yaş olursa
Bengü il tuta olur tacı sen diyor
sözlerimi iyi dinleyin Eğer öttü kendi
oturursan ebedi devlet kuracaksın Biz
ötüken'de oturmadık Anadolu'ya geldik
ama Bilge Kağan'ın bu anlayışı bize
kıvılcım oldu
Selçuklu Osmanlı ve Türkiye Cumhuriyeti
Anadolu'da kurulan Bağımsız Devletler
Osmanlı'nın şiarı neydi Devleti ebet
müddet ebedi yani sonsuza dek yaşayacak
devlet Atatürk
Türkiye Cumhuriyeti ilelebet paylar
kalacaktır dedi ilelebet Cumhuriyet
bağımsız olmayan Türk toplumları ise
dilin söyleyemediğini şiirler ne dile
getirdiler
şiirlerde ebedi devlette ebedi millet
anlayışını ifade ettiler milleti yok
etmek istiyorsanız
önce dilini yok edeceksiniz sonra
aydınlığına imha edeceksiniz Çarlık
rusyası döneminde Türk dünyasında
kurulan edebiyat Bağları sosyal Bağlar
Sovyet hakimiyetiyle beraber
görmezden gelindi Hatta yok sayıldı
20 yüzyıla kadar
Türk coğrafyasında
Sovyet hakimiyetindeki coğrafyada
edebi dil Türkçe iken Çağatay Türkçesi
iken yerine neye bıraktı konuşma
dillerine bu neye benziyor biliyor
musunuz
Trabzonlu Vanlı Kars'ta Erzurumlu Doğu
ve Güneydoğu Egeli
ne ile yazıyoruz hepimiz İstanbul
Türkçesiyle bizim edebi dilimizi sağ mı
Türkçesi Ama bu konuşma dillerin hepsini
yazı dili haline geldiğini düşünelim
böyle oldu ortak dilden ortak edebi
dilden ayrıldılar Ne oldu Sonra Aydınlar
harekete geçti Çünkü kırmızı çizgiydi
Milliyet duygusu ve dil
bunun oluşumu da kolay değil uzak
maziyede uzun zaman diliminde
belli bir devletin büyük bir devletin
çatısı altında yaşayan
Milletler böyle oluşmuş bir millet
ebediyen kimliğini kaybetmiyor
Böylece Uyan şiirleri
Türk milletinin Aslında
Mizaç olarak Evet böyle bir mizacımız
var sosyal ve siyasi olaylar karşısında
ilgisizlik ve umursamazlık aydınları
harekete geçirdi eğitimsizlik cehalet
Has safhada Anadolu'da da Türkistan'da
da
Uyan dedi Akif artık Ölüm uykularından
Uyan diye aykırdı Stalin katliamına
maruz kalan bir jakıp dua dolu
Kazakistan'dan bozkırdan Seslendi o yan
kazak Öter bastı gözünde aç dedi gözünü
aç Uyan kazak kaldır başını
arkasından Mehmet Emin Yurdakul Ey Türk
Uyan diye haykırdı ve Doğu türkistan'a
gidiyoruz Gürbüz
Uyan uykun yeter dedi fakir Uygur Uyan
uykun yeter şimdi Türkiye Cumhuriyeti
olarak biz çok farklı renklerimiz var Ve
bu çok büyük zenginlik türkü ile
kürdüyle çerkeziyle bu topraklar bizim
bir kilimin motifleri gibi İlmek ilmek
dokunmuşuz
Çanakkale'de beraber savaşmışız ve Türk
aydınları bunları da dile getirdiler
şimdi alanım Türkoloji olduğu için ben
kendi coğrafyama Türk dünyasına
şiirlerle sizi Seyre çıkaracağım
Aydınlar
Uyan şiirlerinden sonra tekrar harekete
geçtiler bağımsızlık ve aydınlanma
Avrupa'da başlayan
aydınlanma hareketi Anadolu ve
türkistan'a da sıçradı Kırımlı düşünür
gaspıralının dilde fikirde işte Birlik
şarıyla çıkardığı Tercüman Gazetesi
bütün Türk dünyasına yayılmıştı Çarlık
döneminde ve Sovyet döneminde
1926'da yine bir aydın hareketi Bakü'de
Türkoloji kurultayı toplandı
bu kurultayın amacı neydi Türk dünyasını
bütün Türk dünyasının
farklı dinlere mensup aydınları katıldı
Atatürk çok büyük destek verdi bu
kurultaya
ortak kültür hayatı yaratmak ortak
iletişim dili ortak alfabe Biz ardından
Latin alfabesine geçtik Azerbaycan Latin
alfabesine geçti Sovyet Türklüğü de
geçti on yıl kadar on yıl sonra ne oldu
stalin'in Josef stalin'in emriyle Milli
Mücadele veren varoluş mücadelesi veren
Aydınlar
katledildi Hepsi bu kurultaya katılanlar
Cengiz Aytmatov
Cemile ve Toprak Ana ile tanıyoruz
Aragon diyor ki dünyanın en güzel aşk
hikayesi Cemile için
1963'te yazdığı Toprak Ana da 1938'de
katledilen babasının nereye gömüldüğünü
bilmiyordu 91'de buna ağaçlara uzadı ve
topluma zarar yeniden atabet mezarlığına
İslami usullerle defnedildiler
1963'te Toprak ana'da şöyle sesleniyor
Ata ben sana estelik turgoza Albay mı
senin kayısı geriye kömürü gününde
Atam Töre kul Aytmatov
usul emgimde sağır Nayman Baba ben sana
anıt mezar yaptıramıyorum Çünkü senin
nerede gömülü olduğunu bilmiyorum
babam törü kul Aytmatov Bu eseri mi sana
hitap ediyorum diyor Evet gastralı
Tercüman Gazetesi Toprak Ana bu Anadolu
topraklarına milleti olarak savaşırken
Omuz Omuza macan
Kazakların milli şairi Türkistan'dan
sesleniyor bağrım sen o jakta Men
bucakta kaygıdan Tanju
bulup
Ata miras altın takka uzaktaki kardeşime
bütün Anadolu'daki kardeşlerine Seslendi
Orada şehit olanlara Çanakkale'de
kardeşim sen orada ben burada kaygıdan
kan yutuyoruz bizim adımıza layık mı kul
olmak gel altaylara gidelim diyor
kul olmazlık diz çökmezlik ve boyun
eğmezlik vakur bir tavırla anlatıyor
bunu gidiyoruz Doğu türkistan'a bütün
Türk dillerinden şiirlerle Metinlerle
Türk dünyasını gezdirmeye çalışıyorum
Uygur şair ne diyor
Ben bir varoluş mücadelesi veriyorum
kolum bağlı dilim bağlı boynum bağlı ama
ben halkımdan gücü alıyorum Tıpkı Akif
gibi çok ciddi iletişim var İstiklal
Marşı'nı dinledik zaten İstiklal
Marşı'nın ilk çevirisi Türk dillerine
uyurcaya yapıldı
dedim zincir kurar dedi Boynumda dedim
ölüm vardı dediği yolunda dedim bilezik
çok dedi kolumda dedim Korkar mısın sen
o dedi yak Yak dedim niçin korkmaz sen
dedi Tanrım var dedim Başka yok mu dedi
Salkım var dedim Niye Şu nedir ruhum var
dedim Şükran sen o dedi yak Yak bütün
Türk dillerinden örnek verince herhalde
Uygurca en yakını korkmuyorum halkın var
ruhum var diyor
Türkoloji çok geniş bir alan işim aşkım
Türk dünyası sahada olan biri olarak bu
işi yapmaktan çok mutluyum çok
gururluyum
Türkoloji ile batılılar Niçin
ilgilendiler bize hayran oldukları için
değil kendi köklerini aradılar çünkü
Türkler olmadan Dünya Tarihi Anlaşılamaz
dat bursiyeri olarak Berlin'de
Üniversitesi ve free üniversitede
bulunduğum yıllarda o bilimsel ciddiyete
şahit oldum ve benim hayatımda çok büyük
dönüm noktası oldu İki almanın
kazakça'yı kırgızca'yı uygurcayı
özbekçeyi
kürsülerinde nasıl başarılı sırtlarını
döndüklerinde gerçekten onların Alman
olduğunu fark etmeden o kadar başarılı
Benim hayatımda Almanya hakkında teslim
etmek lazım çok büyük bir dönüm noktası
oldu Onun için Türk dünyasına kendi
alanıma dört elle sarılıp sahaya çıkıp
orada verdiğim kürsülerde verdim
konferanslarda derslerde oranın
dilleriyle dilini konuş
gönlünü Fethet oradaki yabancı
diplomatların Türk dillerini nasıl
konuştuklarına şahit oldum
kendi ana dilleri gibi olmasa da
Kazakların Kırgızların gönlünü okşayacak
tarzda
Azerbaycan'dan bir sesle konuşmamı
noktalamak istiyorum
köklerimizle ilgili
köklerimizden kopmamakla başka köklere
sarılmamakla
sen senlikten çıkmadan ben benlikten
çıkmadan biz
kendimizi unutmadan bizliğimizi
kaybetmeden
indi Öz kökünden üzülen nenem Özge bu
dağlara dizilen menem İndi ne sen sen ne
menem Biz ki biz değildik bize Elveda
hepinizi en içten sevgi ve saygılarımla
selamlıyorum